une maison bombardée détruite par les
flammes dans cette zone contrôlée par
les séparatistes prorus les
affrontements s'intensifie avec l'armée
ukrainienne à tel point que nul ne sait
de quel côté viennent les bombes et les
civils en sont les premières victimes de
l'autre côté dans ce village encore
contrôlé par l'armée ukrainienne
plusieurs habitants font leurs bagages
résignés et un quai de voir les Russes
arrivés chez eux j'ai mon travail ici
on a tous notre vie ici ce n'est pas
beaucoup
ce n'est pas le luxe mais c'est chez
nous
je vais essayer de recommencer ma vie
ailleurs parce qu'ici il n'y a pas de
futur possible
plusieurs sources affirment que des
chats russes seraient entrés sur le
territoire
ukrainien ces dernières 24 heures sur
ces images satellites des charges et des
troupes massés près de bolgorod ici en
route direction Rostov toujours en
Russie mais toujours plus proche des
frontières ukrainiennes à Moscou le
Parlement a entériné la volonté de
Vladimir Poutine de déployer l'armée
dans le Dombas
je propose d'adopter la résolution du
Conseil de l'Assemblée fédérale de
Russie acceptant l'utilisation des
forces armées du pays en dehors du
territoire de la Russie sur la base de
principe et de normes universellement
reconnue du droit international en
réaction l'Ukraine entend renforcer les
rangs de son armée en sollicitant ses
réservistes soit plus de 140 000
personnes
nous devons rapidement envoyer des
forces supplémentaires à l'armée
ukrainienne il y a d'autres formations
militaires en tant que commandant en
chef suprême des forces armées
ukrainiennes j'ai publié un décret sur
la conscription des réservistes pour une
période spéciale
un soldat ukrainien est mort ce mardi 8
au total depuis le début de l'année dans
l'escalade militaire les Nations Unies
continuent d'appeler au cessez-le-feu
alors que les affrontements continuent